we're seeing something very interesting
happening over the last 24 to 48 hours
in the United States on the one hand you
have Donald Trump and the administration
and even many Republicans insisting
everything must open Disney World must
open schools must open and of course it
doesn't really make sense because if
schools had to close when we had a
hundred thousand active cases it's not
really following that it would be safe
to then open the schools when we have
two million active cases or close to it
but what's very interesting is that the
country
fortunately seems to be leaning in the
direction of reality and scaling back
plans to open rather than following the
obvious lies of Donald Trump and opening
more and more and why would they follow
Donald Trump over the last 48 hours the
Trump White House has released a list of
things dr. Anthony foul he got wrong
while Donald Trump was retweeting the
conspiracy theories of former game show
host Chuck Woolery governors and also
many mayors however have to deal with
the day-to-day of increasingly full icy
use increasing hospitalization rates the
mayor of Houston Texas Sylvester Turner
who's a Democrat is proposing a strict
to weak shot down even the Republican
governor in Texas Greg Abbott is talking
about stricter guidelines they've put in
a mandatory mask order in California
over the last two days we've seen the
Democratic governor Gavin Newsom say
indoor restaurants have to close again
close wineries close movie theaters
close zoos museums certainly bars must
close a Los Angeles and San Diego are
saying we're not opening schools the
fall semester the fall the school year
in the fall is going to start online
only Oregon has said once again no
gatherings of more than ten people
Kentucky Fried Chicken or I guess now
it's just called KFC they are telling
franchises in a lot of these states
you've got to stop indoor dining and
this makes sense and even the economic
arguments fall short because the short
term benefit of opening things too
quickly is going to backfire it's going
to evaporate and you're going to end up
with a much worse economic situation if
you have a big relapse effect and in the
end the long-term results are going to
be based on flattening the curve in a
serious manner but
that's not this administration's
priority Trump's priority is getting
reelected in November
that's his gambit his idea is anything I
can do in the next three and a half
months that will make it seem as though
life is returning to normal will benefit
me politically and that is the only
thing that he cares about now
unfortunately the timing hasn't worked
out because instead of a nice gap now
leading into the election with few cases
and few deaths we're seeing a massive
resurgence which shouldn't surprise us
because when we got down to 20,000 cases
a day States went crazy reopening and
now we're seeing that resurgence now I'm
gonna be totally upfront with you guys
about something because this came up on
the bonus show yesterday sort of briefly
and people wrote to me and they said
David I we want to hear more about this
I know some people may be mad because
not everybody is in a position to be
able to do this because they have
different types of jobs things are
potentially going to get so bad here in
the United States and it's even going to
bleed into Massachusetts I am seriously
looking at finding the is it possible I
could do the show from somewhere else in
the fall where I could get a break from
what's going on in the United States and
just be somewhere else and by that I
mean another country now of course the
problem is Americans are banned from
much of the world right now because it's
so bad here so I've not looked into it
in a huge amount of detail but would it
be possible to put the masks on take a
coronavirus test quarantine 14 days and
if I'm going to be you know just
buckling in and riding it out for three
or four months maybe that is something I
would actually be interested in doing
because the reality is what it
increasingly looks like is the best-case
best-case it takes two months for a
lockdown to have a big impact we saw it
in New York if Texas Florida you know
etc lockdown today we're looking at
large case numbers at least until
mid-september they don't look like they
want to do full lockdown so we could be
looking at this going well into the fall
if Joe Biden wins in November and we get
the most optimistic timeline with an
early use vaccine for health care
workers at that point in time
optimistically things aren't going to
really dramatically improve until
20:21 that that's just an unfortunate
reality Joe Biden will hopefully take
over then treatments and vaccinations
will hopefully start to become a reality
in the short term hopefully we see
governors and mayors do the right thing
but when you're seeing 5 7 10 15,000
cases a day in some states like we're
seeing right now the best cases you need
months to come down from numbers that
high and I understand that I'm truly
privileged to live in Massachusetts I
can't imagine what my friends in Florida
Arizona California Texas are going
through right now and it's going to
remain incredibly ugly for a long time
if there's any good news it's that some
governors and mayors seem to be taking
this seriously let me know what's going
on in your city or state I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and remember to get the
daily audio podcast on Spotify stitch or
iTunes Google Play wherever you prefer
to listen to your podcasts